[Música]
[Aplausos]
para poder hablar de adicciones es
necesario poner énfasis
en que la persona que la sufre no es
ningún vicioso
ni un mañoso ni siquiera tiene una
debilidad moral la adicción como tal
constituye una enfermedad una enfermedad
que tiene signos y síntomas que son
detectables y además son prevenibles
una enfermedad que es bio psicosocial
biológicamente en el adicto se ve
comprometido el sistema de gratificación
y recompensas
la manera en el que cerebro produce la
felicidad
psicológicamente hay un dolor que el
adicto necesita aliviar ese dolor puede
haber sido causado por múltiples cosas
como abandono
violencia
abuso etcétera
y socialmente la manera en que nos
vinculamos afectivamente a las personas
pueden jugar un papel fundamental en que
si puede ser un factor de riesgo
para caer dentro de la adicción o un
factor de protección para evitar caer
también es importante darnos cuenta de
que las relaciones sociales en el adicto
se ven distorsionadas uno de los más
grandes investigadores en el tema de
adicciones
el doctor gabor mate dice que es
imposible entender una adicción
si primero nos preguntamos
qué alivio encuentra la persona en la
droga o qué esperanza se encuentra
yo nací en el año de 1979
primer hijo de un matrimonio muy joven
mi madre tenía 19 años
mi papá 21
gracias a sus esfuerzos pudieran las
escuelas a los colegios se preocupaban
por mi salud física por mi salud
emocional
y puedo decirte que desde bb hasta en
mis 8 años mi vida fue miel y dulzura
nunca fue un niño bien portado
siempre tuve problemas de conducta me
iba muy bien en la escuela pero siempre
tenía reportes siempre tenía quejas y lo
explica muy bien mi padre
cuando a la edad de cinco años
escribe un poema al que nombró pequeño y
habilitó está cortito se los voy a
reclamar dice
pequeño diablito que corre y que vuela
demonio que rompe inquietudes y vasos
que cada mañana llorando a la escuela y
siempre te espero tendiendo mis brazos
azote del barrio de toda la escuela así
lo prohíba regaños y a gritos el día te
pasas con palos y horquetas y llegas a
casa con cien amiguitos aquila te llama
tu abuelo materno por fama que tiene
desde niño tremendo más nada en la vida
me hace tan feliz de tenerte a mi lado a
ti josé luís
como podrán ver
explica muy bien mi padre de verdad mis
problemas de conducta pero también
explicaba esa situación de que fui muy
amado muy querido muy cuidado
cuándo
cumplió los 8 años mi hermano menor
carlos de 3
mis papás empiezan un proceso de
divorcio
cuando esto sucede
nosotros ni cuenta nos dimos de ellos
tuvieron mucho mucho cuidado en que no
nos percatáramos de las peleas o de las
discusiones tuvieron mucho cuidado en
esa parte al terminar el proceso de
divorcio nos quedamos a vivir con papá
los primeros años vivimos en casa de mi
abuelo de mis abuelos maternos
amigo para lo que haya seguido
pero mi madre salió del país
era poco el contacto que tenía físico
con ella y eventualmente por teléfono
por cartas
he aquí
una situación de que como niño yo no
entendía razones yo no sabía porque mi
madre se había ido y no quería
entenderlo lo único que sabía era que la
persona que más amaba en el mundo que
era mi madre no estaba a mi lado y eso
me dolía
y terminó la secundaria
y empiezo a consumir eventualmente
marihuana a la edad de alrededor de 13
años
la fumada con unos chavos que iban a
lavar carros a la colonia que montaban
en bicicleta y a mí me gustaba montar en
bicicleta y en el primer la primera vez
que tuve contacto con la marihuana sentí
que era para mí
llenó un vacío o alguna situación que me
hizo sentir muy bien pero yo todavía no
sabía lo que la adicción me tenía a mi
preparado
paso la preparatoria mi consumo de
marihuana se hace habitual
y empiezo a probar otras sustancias
pastillas cocaína alcohol
y empiezo a bajar mis notas
aún así termina la preparatoria me fui
a estudiar a guadalajara
y fue ahí donde realmente
mi uso de drogas se convirtió en un
verdadero problema los compañeros con
los que vivía y yo diariamente
consumíamos todo tipo de drogas
especialmente cocaína para cualquier
cosa en cualquier momento me había
convertido en un adicto
recuerdo una vez que sentía tan grande
un vacío existencial que no sabía que
había pasado por mi vida
que llame por teléfono mi padre para
decirle cómo me sentía y yo creo que él
me noto tal mal y al otro día él ya
estaba en guadalajara buscando ayuda
para tratar mi adicción
mi internet
y dura algún tiempo limpio volví a casa
me dispuse a terminar mi carrera al poco
tiempo de entrar a la universidad de
vuelta recaí
pero esta vez la caída fue en espiral
empecé a sustituir la cocaína por la
metanfetamina el cristal
empecé a vender drogas para poder
solventar los gastos que mi adicción me
producida
empecé a tener muchos conductos
antisociales
nosotros empezamos mis amigos y yo a
relacionar con personas
que se dedicaban al tráfico de drogas y
nos convencieron de llevar droga al
extranjero
obviamente caí preso
me detuvieron
por el cargo de transportación posesión
e intento y distribución de cocaína
en el momento que me ponen a mí las
esposas en las manos
sabía que un largo tiempo en la prisión
me esperaba
en camino
de la detención a la penitenciaría atado
de pies y de manos yo no podría yo no
podía parar de pensar en que había
pasado con ese niño
que quería ser biólogo marino
que era noble educado amado como había
terminado siendo un felón convicto
en el extranjero
dentro de prisión
me vi envuelto en pandillas en riñas
inclusive estuve un año en confinamiento
solitario en una celda de dos por cuatro
por una pelea
al terminar
mi sentencia y salir de prisión me
prometí y me juré no volver a consumir
pero al mes de mi liberación ya me
encontraba de vuelta en el mismo hoyo
en una caída libre sin paracaídas
volvía a vender sustancias para poder
pagar
me consumo mis patrones de consumo
empecé a
a trabajar en una compañía de un
familiar mío pero fue poco tiempo porque
me volvieron a internar en un centro de
la rehabilitación en el que salí y dure
tres meses es limpio y muy volví volví a
recaer
ya toda mi familia estaba cansada estaba
desesperada de que todo el mundo ponía
de su parte para que yo me convirtiera
en una mejor persona para que yo dejara
las drogas y yo no podía encontrar los
recursos internos para poder hacerlo
me era prácticamente imposible
recuerdo un día que estaba en mi
habitación viendo las fotos fascina la
pared de mi hija
en un estado deplorable
con un llanto inconsolable empecé a
sentir que realmente ya no podía seguir
así
que necesitaba una ayuda y le hablo a mi
padre por teléfono y él con todas las
dudas del mundo dice te voy a ayudar y
me lleva un centro de rehabilitación
otra vez duró poco en el centro de
rehabilitación a la primera oportunidad
que tuve me escape me escape para que no
lo sé no me quería derogar pero tampoco
quería la ayuda
es una incongruencia
que caracteriza también esta enfermedad
es como cuando vas como ir al médico y
decirle al doctor qué es lo que quieres
que te recete
me aborda mi padre y me dice oye josé
luís pues qué es lo que quieres hacer se
me dificulta mucho poderte ayudar cuando
no te quieres dejar echar la mano y me
habla de un centro de rehabilitación
que se llama está base de tratamiento
avanzaron adicciones y yo acepto que me
lleven para allá
y ahí empecé a comprender realmente qué
es lo que me pasaba
y hubo mucha gente
que estaba comprometida en ayudarme en
hacerme sentir que valía en ver mis de
frente trabajar mis defectos en verdes
virtudes en sanar mis heridas ya vivir
mi espiritualidad
ahí conocí
a dos señoras que tienen un corazón de
oro gigante tan gigante que cabemos
todos los adictos de la ciudad
mis madrinas martelly trespalacios ellas
me invitaron a quedarme a trabajar esto
fue muy conmovedor para mí porque unas
personas que ni siquiera me conocían
tenían confianza en que yo podía hacer
las cosas bien
y me empezaron a capacitar y me mandaban
a conferencias a talleres a cursos
y yo me empecé a sentir bien sirviendo
ayudando a los demás y bien recuerdo
porque en mi proceso de rehabilitación
leí una oración de san francisco de asís
que decía que a veces para encontrarse
uno mismo es necesario perderse en los
demás
y fue así
como fui trabajando mi espiritualidad
cuando hablo de espiritualidad
personalmente
yo no estoy hablando de la aceptación de
un dios que puede ser religioso sin ser
se puede ser religioso o no y ser
espiritual siempre y cuando te basas
bajo sus principios como cual es como la
honestidad como la honradez la
la compasión
el ser agradecido
y esa es la manera en que veo mi
espiritual mi espiritualidad y es muy
curioso para tratar de vivir lo más
pegado a eso es muy curioso porque
cuando yo estaba chavo
en un rebelde un rebelde sin causa lo
mejor
y lo curioso de esto es que cuando
empiezo a vivir bajo principios
espirituales
guiándome por lo que se me enseñó por lo
que se me inculcó
constituye para mí hoy un verdadero acto
de rebeldía porque porque vemos en
afuera en las calles una una veneración
a la recupera todos los chavos quieren
ser sicarios al menos los que muchos de
los que llegan a los centros de
rehabilitación
hay una
una identificación con los personajes de
las narco series entonces algo está mal
realmente en nuestra sociedad
entonces constituye para mí un verdadero
actuar rebeldía a vivir en las
circunstancias que está la sociedad bajo
principios espirituales
yo te exhorto
a que analices los esfuerzos que se
están haciendo para combatir esta
enfermedad
en materia política la adicción es un
tema de seguridad pública
cuando en realidad el fondo del problema
es un problema de salud es una situación
de salud
claro que vulnera la seguridad de las
personas pero sería como atacar el
síntoma y no entrar a trabajar la
enfermedad
entonces
hay organizaciones civiles como está but
que tienen tantos años trabajando en
adicciones
que yo creo
ya llegó el momento en que nuestros
dirigentes
se acerquen y escuchen qué es lo que
ellos tienen que decir acerca de esta
materia de adicciones para abordarlo de
una manera más efectiva
gracias a todos los esfuerzos de estas
personas
que se comprometieron en mi
rehabilitación
aquel niño que quería ser biólogo marino
que se descarriló fue un exconvicto el
día de hoy pues se está preparando en
una especialidad en psicología clínica y
me dedico
ayudar a las personas que han estado en
la misma situación que yo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]